please to have on certainly again I just
described in the previous segment to our
new NBCSN audience this is not this
first man's from pre-draft rodeo calling
it to the show he literally is our go-to
guy before the draft ever here to give
you all an idea of what it's like to get
ready for a draft and this is a draft
unlike any other obviously he is the
general manager of your Atlanta Falcons
he's Thomas Dimitrov how are you Thomas
rich how are you I'm doing well 13 13
years going into this this is crazy it
is crazy right I mean and if this is
unlike any other I know you talked to
Peter King about it but walk me through
what your setup is you're the general
manager of the Atlanta Falcons and you
were doing this draft from where from
your from your home your basement walk
me through how this is going to work for
you yeah okay so responsible to have
draft central Atlanta Falcons 2020 in my
office so in my just off my living room
okay
I have an office set up there had three
really cool screens on there as it was
one will cover have enough networks in
the middle of them then we'll have draft
boards on each side so needs boards from
teams etc etc and then they'll also be
you know on my draft ones in there I
have two big almost 30 inch monitors on
my desk one side will be the offensive
draft board one side the defensive draft
board and and I'll be connected out to
all the other people that I you know the
main players in all of this so you know
Dan Quinn Rich McKay Arthur Blank our
College Director and our in our
personnel director and we'll all be
communicating it's going to be a hub
here I'm only allowed one technology
person here at my house and that person
can't be Dan Quinn from you know he was
an electrician back when he was 18 and
menacing and claiming that he's you know
it has to be a legit tech guy right and
so I'll put him down in the basement and
he'll be down there if I ever need him
help to come up in his hands match suit
it's probably exaggerated but he will
come on us to affected right yeah yeah
so that's that's how we're operating so
Wow and where are you and you've got
these the apparent backup where your
phone line muted with the 31 other
general managers on on a telephone line
as well does that is that a true part
about this setup that's exactly right so
that'll be connected to the other 31
general managers and the league office
you know that Kenny fuel and the people
at the league office that we have to
connect with will also have our own our
own set up where I'm connected with the
rest of our staff the peripheral part of
the staff who are really important of
course there's there are a lot of layers
to it and we have basically it's it's
the five of us or six of us in the
middle and then there's a whole bunch of
layers outside that we're connected to
understand this we are using baseline
technology we're not we're trying not to
go overboard on this we have the
capacity to do that man the ability to
do that but we're trying to make it as
simple as possible rich so that if
something does go down it's going to be
a fairly easy fix so how often are you
gonna check that mute button with the 31
other general managers on that phone
line how meticulous are you going to be
about that the other thing is if
anything does go down and you know this
I'll pick up the phone and call my buddy
left Sneed and we'll be on ourselves I
love it I love it and where's the worst
where's your lava lamp and all this
Thomas figure out the design we were
just talking today about how am I gonna
have the food set up like I write I
can't cook is someone gonna drop it off
on my front porch and doesn't really
matter well I just you know eat beans
and rice I don't know well you're still
vegan right you're still vegan correct
well I'm pescetarian so I hate to
disappoint you I have I do eat some fish
here and there but I mainly plant-based
but that's how I know that you know I
used to call you Thomas dimitrov but I
know it's there there is no meat in and
dimitrov so now that we're giving you
all the information you need prior to
this draft by uh right here on the Rich
Eisen show Thomas dimitrov joining me
here on the program Peter King was on
yesterday I know you talked to him he
thinks that there might be fewer trades
because of how this I guess it is it
sounds like a rigmarole I know that you
mentioned how that's basic technology
but
does seem like there's so much going on
in so many different screens and lines
and virtual maybe zoom rooms or whatever
you might use that there may be just
fewer trades just because you've got to
use your brain equity on just the the
pics and things like that do you think
that might be the case Thomas you know
what it was really interesting in our
general managers Advisory Committee
meeting him was pretty outspoken as you
could imagine we all have a lot of heavy
opinions you can only imagine and when
it was brought to our attention like
about you know the topic of trade would
we adjust the trade setup would we
eliminate I mean there was so much
outcry within a half a second you can
imagine this is a very aggressive
general manager wave these days right
it's not they're not sitting back on
their hands they want to trade and
everyone wants to trade so I really
believe they'll still be the trades
everyone will get it figured out most
people have the technology set up in the
building in their excuse me in their
house now so they're playing with it now
to make sure they are dialed in so they
are ready to go and trade I believe on
on drafting I do I do believe however
there will be more discussions the week
before the trade to get some things set
up you know general compensation set up
with certain teams if something did
happen that's how I think it's going to
happen a little bit more of that let's
dig into that a little bit more Thomas
how does that work where you call up a
colleague yours and say if this happens
let's just keep this in our top drawer
and I'll call you and we'll pull this
trade off is that how it works
that's exactly right that's exactly
right it's hey you know les you know
we're picking here you're picking there
we're interested in moving up you're
interested in moving back potentially
here will be the proposed compensation
what do you think yeah we'll think about
that nothing cast in stone if it happens
and we're interested well strike the
call we'll strike the deal it'll be
right around this but now you know as
well as I do that happens and then also
in the heat of the battle someone's
telling me they have five more picks on
the line and you know two more players
that are going to be thrown in can you
do it and obviously at that point you're
aborting the mission okay no doubt about
it has there ever been in your tenure
a colleague of viewers that does that in
advance to set up a smoke screen to make
you think that somebody's doing this and
then there's a rumor that goes around I
mean how do you do you ever sit there
and go how real is this hypothetical
conversation yeah I think so as long as
there you have the agreement that it is
hypothetical I think a lot of them can
be like really who knows percentages
could be 10% that it's going to go
through again I just think there's going
to be more of that now there are
definitely hypotheticals where there are
smoke screens out there and you know you
know in the draught world you know the
guys that you can deal with and they're
they're real enough deals you also know
everyone's you know vying for their own
team right and we're working for their
own team and making sure that they're
doing the best for their own team that
said you have to have good relationships
in this league to be able to secure a
deal if you're armed with someone that
you know is a is a you know perennial bs
guy it's kind of tough to think big
you're gonna get anything done you might
like that bs guy by the way it's true
there's business and then there's
personal I totally irk you on that and
and last one for you on on just the
technical part of it Thomas we had your
colleague in Division Jason light from
the Bucks on last week he said that
there was going to be a mock draft where
everybody gets on and tried just to try
all the technology out is that happening
did that happen what can you tell me
about that yeah yeah that will happen
and you know I think it's gonna be you
know they're projecting it to be a
couple hours probably and it'll be real
I think it's I think it's at the
beginning of next week is when we're
doing it and I should know that right on
your schedule it'll be on your schedule
you'll figure it out I've been relying
on my Alissa quite a bit lately and it's
kind of tough when we're from this far
away of course she's up in Jersey right
now and we have to keep track of it all
but that isn't going to be important of
course I'll be interested to see how
smoothly it flows because there are
elements to it and nuances to you know
draft day that that are going to change
of course and you know
I will say this interestingly enough
when when I came from New England our
draft room was probably eight to ten
people in the draft room Atlanta 45 to
50 you couldn't know obviously very
different we just everyone has different
approaches this will be very interesting
to be back in the house here doing a
draft as I'm going to with basically me
and my 12 year old son right so I'm
welcoming the piece of it to see how it
is that's amazing do you know is the
Commissioner gonna be on it involved in
that mock draft too just to get it all
set up do you know that I do not know I
don't know okay so cuz I mean if he is
then you can't just you know screw
around and say you're drafting a kicker
just to have fun during your mock draft
you know that's your first rounder
Thomas dimitrov you're on the Rich Eisen
show is your board set right now
where does your what does your board
look like right now Thomas our board is
set and yeah it's set we've done we're
still doing some minor adjustments and
massaging as we call it we've talked
about massaging your draft board yeah
that's that's a great vision right
but the reality there's no you know
there's where we're moving boards
nowadays but rarely are we on magnetic
cords especially in this in this remote
remote situation right right we're all
on our screens now and they've come so
far other screens but anyway we're in
the process of doing that and we're
really close to it dan and I coach
Gwynne and I meet basically every
morning from 8:00 to noon watching video
together in a sort of a zoom mode you
know we're watching or teams whatever
whatever we decide and we have great
discussion of course the video isn't as
clear as you'd like it to be you know as
your as your you know as its
transmitting but great conversation
great discussion and we're able to
discuss our draft board day in and day
out and I think we're in a good spot and
when you're you're looking at your draft
board do you have at the top of the
draft board who you think is the number
one overall pick in the draft like say
borrow or chase young or is it your the
way that you're viewing things when
you're sitting there at 16 how does that
work yeah that's a great point what we
do is know we have the entire draft
board up as we do
the talent to be yes as it relates to us
but we have you know by each position by
grade you know we have our guys listed
from from top talent to the bottom you
know at that specific position so you
know it's it's it does apply to us of
course but what we do is we move down a
few few sections and we we kind of
project to what will be potentially
there at 16 or if we decide to move up
to 10 or back to 24 whatever the numbers
are we'll project that way we have
really what we do is we spend a lot of
time on our scenarios rich and we may
have 10 different scenarios plus you
know you could go exponentially more
than that if you really wanted to but we
spend a lot of time on scenarios I think
that's that's a prepare in times of
peace bleed lesson times of war idea
whose quote is that I'm still is it is
it Patton's quote no I said I said I
said it Tom Thomas you know I mean let's
you know look there it's the
everything's an evaluation with you
these days Thomas I guess it's that time
it's a pattern quote Christopher is a
chris is a confirmed Pat very good okay
I like you using that so all right now
who's the top your draft board
is it a quarterback oh that's a great
question right yes I thought you're
gonna ask it was it was a quarterback
somewhere in the southeast yes yeah
is that is it is it is it well I
wouldn't tell you exactly who it is just
because they'll probably you know I
think that's like a major faux pas on
our world but so the reality is he is
one of the very very very very best in
the league but potentially excuse me in
this in the n-c-double-a so yes he's
okay
quite high on our board where do you say
where do you stand with that individual
that we're not naming as potential Tom
Brady look-alike you've been hearing
that a lot about burrow what's your
evaluation to him yeah no he honestly is
a he's a heck of a football player and
he's just got such a combination of not
only his skills his moxie and his his
his intelligence and his ability to work
the field as well as you know his
athleticism gosh he just seems like he
comes to the table with a full
package and he's got he's got an air
about them as you know that is very
cocksure which is is good for him right
he's a guy that is very very you know
sort of aggressive in his ways in a
really cool cool manner I think a team
is gonna do well with him for sure
Thomas Dimitrov the Atlanta Falcons GM
few minutes left with him here on the
Rich Eisen show the Todd Gurley signing
Thomas obviously him coming back to that
area we all know he's a Georgia Bulldog
that's just a huge signing what's your
concern about his health Thomas that's
been the conversation about him for
about a year and a half now well you
know it was interesting because we've
talked a lot about it and when I say
we're very comfortable with it we're
comfortable with all the information
that we have it took us a while to to
release it only because you know like
anything you're crossing T's dotting
eyes as I mentioned recently yet you
can't of course put your hands on any of
your acquisitions Todd Gurley being one
of those so it is a little more
complicated we do haven't worked into
our contracts however that we're
protected and the players protected
given in you know today's situation with
with kovat and such and so until we you
know get Todd here in our building to
that point we are we are communicating
with him through our you know our Doc's
and our our trainer and such and making
sure that he is you know feeling good
and his workout situation is appropriate
where appropriate of course and making
sure he's healing up properly and
rehabbing properly whatever that may be
even if it is or isn't that he's you
know feeling healthy I mean he's
approaching things in the right way we
can't wait to get him here we have
significant expectations for him as he
does for this organization and we're
excited about I know he's gonna be
wearing number 21 and that's that's a
big number here in Atlanta I know Thomas
I heard that story and you know why is
21 not retired there I know that you've
got so many things on your plate but is
that ever convinced is there ever
conversation is you generally manage
this team about John's number it took
that's a great point and as I generally
manage I usually steer clear of of those
sort of bigger picture ideas that maybe
an owner and a president and ahead of
the competition
committee would take care of so I'll
leave ours are enriched to mull over
that right issue yeah of course beyond
that's it's a really good point
I mean he's he was a fantastic player
interestingly enough a little aside I've
been talking to a number of different
guys the idea that this city has been
searching for that energy sense since
Dion whether it's on the offensive or
defensive side you know a personality
like that that can take the city over
you know I think there are some players
that can do that and I I think it's
interesting to of our free edge and
acquisitions feel like they probably
want to do that you know one being Todd
Gurley in his own way of course and one
being Dante Fowler who who has such
energy that I think he'd love to take
the city by storm well and in a few
minutes I have left with you here while
we're so your guy who's signed a running
back to the largest contract in the
league at the time as you did to devote
with daunt Devonta Freeman a couple
years ago and now you've signed somebody
with obviously a huge track record and a
lotta upside but a potential injury
history despite his young age in in a
one-year deal in Gurley what what what's
the market for running backs do you
think from your perspective as a general
manager in the NFL these days your your
philosophy on that yeah you know what we
we definitely did that with Devonta
Freeman and he was you know he was a
heck of a football player for us and we
we appreciated it all at that point he
was very instrumental in our you know an
artist and our 16 run to the Super Bowl
and such and we felt that at that time
was the right thing to do now as you
move forward I believe as a league as we
move forward I look and realize like
there are some really really good
football players out there some at the
top of the draft some in the middle of
the draft the thing with this position
as you know the the idea that you can
win and significantly win and produce
with running backs in the middle of the
draft is a really a attractive things
for a thing for a lot of people and you
know not to say that the position is
devalued I just think it's such an
important position and maybe not a
position that you're holding someone for
many many years at right so I think
there's a big turnover there and the
point
I think you can find some really
talented players whether they're at the
first you know top 20 and the draft or
whether they're at you know around four
or five or six so I love that you know
it's it's pick pick your you know choose
the way you want to approach it right
you want to put money into it understand
that it you know sometimes may not be
that long-lived so before I let you go
Thomas you you hail from the New England
system if I had told you that Tom Brady
would be in your division at some point
you would have said what because he is
now as I'm sure you're aware said I will
use a word that you probably appreciate
inscrutable it is it really is
unimaginable that he is in this division
I thought he was heading west and I know
that you know that he's down the street
is incredible for this division of
course I still think he's the best to
play the game and it you know hopefully
continues to focus on other things too
like his I don't know wasn't he doing
something there with the tompa bay or
something like compa bay yeah I mean
he's you know I mean the man's demands a
walk in trademark I guess you know you
never know that do you want to help
everybody out with that Chris right
there yeah so inscrutable it's an
adjective
just derivative from the Latin word
inscrutability is it means impossible to
understand or interpret you Thomas I
mean you're just a jack-of-all-trades
you really are honestly I'm gonna give
you a little tidbit on it I use that
word because there's much easier to to
articulate them unfathomable we we mess
around with our tongue twisting there
alright last thing last thing for you
Andy Reid had that had that workout
elliptical or or I guess was that was it
the Stairmaster and we think it was I
mean do you think he's using that do you
think he's really using that he had a
towel over the yeah he had a towel over
the screen of it do you think he's using
that Tom aside after you win a Super
Bowl you're using you really think so
is that in your setup room - it's gotta
be right your workout I have I have more
of the stationary bike thing as you know
I'm more of a cyclist and cycling
aficionado
oh you are the man Thomas thanks for the
time
let's chat after the draft to see what
you come up with if you don't mind I
would love and I do not get on my spin
bike in a mob Union at all maybe you
should Thomas I maybe you should thanks
for the call thank you
one or only Thomas Dimitra longtime
friend in front of them